the moment the uk left the european
union
the end of one torturous political saga
the start
of another within weeks of brexit day
uk negotiators were back in brussels it
didn't take long for the divisions to
emerge
our differences come as
no surprise especially after only one
round of negotiations
but some are very very difficult
as the covert pandemic hit talks moved
online but stubborn sticking points
remained
access to fishing waters along with how
closely the uk would follow
eu rules and how the deal would be
enforced and governed
it is the first trade agreement that
will lead to more barriers to trade
rather than reduce the barriers to trade
so in a sense the uk and the eu were
really concerned about well how do we
ensure that we continue having great
access to each other's markets but also
the freedom
to do what we like on the side and to
prevent the other from
accessing the market and distorting
competition
for boris johnson's predecessor
resolving that perennial brexit tension
between access and control was to prove
an impossible task
in divorce talks with the eu theresa may
initially aimed for a more distant
relationship
but faced with rejection in brussels was
forced to change tack
decisions again boris that had
consequences back home though
with the then foreign secretary boris
johnson resigning in protest at the plan
saying it risked the uk becoming a
colony of the eu
order and mps agreed
the nose to the left 344
rejecting the deal three times forced
into a brexit delay she had previously
ruled out
theresa may resigned but with enormous
and enduring gratitude
to have had the opportunity to serve the
country
i love taking over in number 10 boris
johnson
promised a fresh approach to
negotiations and a hard deadline
can you make a promise today to the
british public
that you will not go back to brussels
and ask for another delay to brexit
yes and
a last-minute meeting with the irish
prime minister eventually paved the way
for a deal
but it was an election that followed as
the commons became
stuck in a stalemate and refused to back
the prime minister's plans
vowing to get brexit done boris johnson
fought the campaign
promising an oven-ready deal the exit
poll
is predicting is indicating it's a
conservative
win the strategy worked a thumping
majority was gifted to the conservatives
brexit now certain but still far from
done
boris johnson promised an end to
squabbling about the eu
but in reality his divorce deal left
loose ends on one
key issue the new mechanism to keep the
irish border open
ceded powers to brussels and created a
new frontier in the irish sea something
the prime minister had previously said
he would never do
and that's why arguments over this
border flared again during this year's
talks
when boris johnson tabled laws that
would unpick
parts of the agreement he'd signed just
months before
they were eventually withdrawn but not
before this shock admission from a
cabinet minister
yes this does break international law in
a very specific and limited way
amid anger from the eu and with trust
running low
negotiations seem to be petering out i
concluded
that we should get ready for january the
first with arrangements
that are more like australia's based on
simple principles
of global free trade whether that was
genuine or just theatrics negotiations
did restart
mr belmir was a success in london but
with little progress to report
it was left to the politicians to
intervene
a dinner between boris johnson and the
eu commission president
was arranged at first the gaps between
the two sides seemed too wide
but then at the last minute a
breakthrough and a deal
so is this the end of the brexit story
we haven't really changed up
trade policy relative to third countries
if brexit means we can have our own
trade policy we're going to have to go
back and negotiate changes with these
other countries
so no no it's gonna run and run more
than 50 months since the country voted
to leave
we now have some clarity on the
relationship we'll have with our closest
neighbour
the true legacy of brexit though will be
how the uk
uses its newfound freedoms rob powell's
sky news
in westminster